last free webinar we discussed about
host pathogen
interaction
and also we discussed the contribution
of genomics and bioinformatics
to our understanding of infectious
diseases and how omits data can help us
to study
viral genomes dna variation host gene
expression protein abundance and
composition properties
of microbial communities
last friday we also hosted
another free webinar on the epidemiology
of sarskoff
ii and how novel variants in research
literature on mass media might play a
role in the vaccine roll out
around the world we heard from dr
gus kuzlus who is the head of department
of pathobiological sciences
the director of division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine
biomed at the school of veterinary
medicine at louisiana state university
he is also the principal investigator of
louisiana biomedical research network
lbrn who is a collaborator of pine
biotech
and the president of the national
association of
idea principal investigator dr
kucilis shared his insights on the
biology of sars koftu
its replication and highlighted the
significance of specific
mutations that have been detected
in various populations around the world
in the later part elia brodsky ceo
of pinebiotic helped the audience
understand bioinformatics analysis of
available genomic data on sars cove 2
and how it reveals the important
considerations for vaccine rollout
and serves as a great example of the
application of bioinformatics for
infectious disease research
as part of our upcoming training program
for students
and researchers with a focus on
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
today's webinar will discuss about
finding ngs data from public
repositories like
ncbi and how to formulate a research
question
from such data
for those joining us for the first time
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omits logic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are part of a
matrix community managed by pi biotech
over the past couple of years we have
seen participants from all over the
world
join our omits logic training programs
take online course work and utilize our
big data
analysis tools in various research
projects
before we head to today's discussion let
me share with you
some feedback we have received from
previous participants who have been
part of such omics logic programs
especially from africa
here we have dr irene day and he
proposed
a research project on ngs
transcriptomics
analysis of malaria plasmodium
while he was doing an omics logic
program with us
we also had miyambu uh
do this research project where he
proposed the in-depth transcriptomic
analysis to determine the response to
inhibition of pkna and pknb
by m tuberculosis moving ahead
for those of us who are joining us for
the first time
what we are discussing today and
throughout all of our programs as a
result of
hard work by an amazing team led by
company co-founders
dr alfred tober and dr leonid brodsky dr
tober comes from a medical background
and has
extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and has been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of
many research projects and initiatives
that support
data science training and applications
in medicine
dr brocky is the director
of the tower bioinformatics research
center
at university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics he
has
numerous publications in mathematics and
bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
under his leadership the tauber research
center started collaborations
with research teams at such universities
as
the university of california san
francisco institute pasture
tulane university and many others where
research labs are working on
cutting-edge research projects studying
viral and bacterial infections and
designing
novel drugs and vaccines to treat and
prevent
infectious diseases
in this bioinformatics for infectious
disease program in collaboration with
the university of ghana and noguchi
memorial institute
for medical research you will also have
the opportunity to collaborate
and be mentored by the speakers that you
see here
we have dr anita gansha who is leading
the biophometics for
infectious disease program she is a
senior
research fellow at noguchi memorial
institute for medical research at the
university of ghana
her area of work is in genomics of
infectious diseases
she applies data analytics to explore
pathogen genome data for signatures of
the emergence and spread of drug
resistant
pathogens virulence pathogens in
response to disease control
interventions dr gansha has been an
active participant
in our recent omics logic programs
and is now a collaboration and mentor
for the upcoming program
we have dr mohit mazumdar who is our
omics logic project
mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis
dr majumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with
industry and academia elio brodsky is
prime biotech co-founder
and ceo in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industry and academic partners that are
applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics
to a variety of biotechnology and
clinical applications
and dr harpreet core is a certified
omics logic trainer and
expert information who will guide the
hands-on sessions and
assist participants with projects and
analysis during the program
her era of specialization is in genomics
and machine learning
i would now like to invite elia to talk
more about the public data repositories
and a vast amount of information that
we can learn by analyzing and studying
those data
elia over to you
thank you very much pizza let me share
my screen
welcome back everyone i'm hoping that
majority of you
are also uh have joined the previous
webinar that we had and if we have not
then i'm hoping that beeps would be able
to send it to you
so in this program that is coming up
we want to focus on practical
bioinformatics tools
that you can learn to effectively apply
to a variety of different types of data
and so we want to get to the part of the
data and we want to understand
how the analysis techniques can help us
extract
some meaningful insights into the
problems that we
are interested in as researchers or as
citizen scientists as people that are
surrounded by biomedical challenges in
research and
in different applications and so when we
thought of this program we wanted to
combine
what we typically do in our typical
programs that are structured
around training bioinformatics training
with elements that are designed for
researchers so
how to leverage these skills
in answering research questions and
how can we become efficient
at finding data that can answer the
questions that we have
and so the idea behind omics logic
came from that how to find data sets
how to explore and visualize those data
sets to understand
what the data set could be used for
how to read through publications that we
think
have addressed a particular topic and
apply the same methods to a data set of
our own
and how to gain reliable insight and
understanding
about a particular topic through the
lens of data or through the lens of
bioinformatics
so over the course of the past
maybe a couple of years we've dealt
with thousands of students from around
the world
many of whom have went on to publish
their research
or present their research at different
conferences
based on the training that they have
been able to
get and our hope for this program and
for this webinar
is to allow you to see
how you can get started and it all
starts with data
so that's really where we want to turn
to in just a few more minutes
now the program itself is going to be
focused on infectious diseases
and the infectious diseases um are
a very specific topic because it has to
do
with multiple elements and we started
introducing those
elements in our last webinar these
elements include
the host the human or the
vector perhaps and the pathogen
and so when we look at the interaction
between the host the vector and the
pathogen
there is a number of additional kind of
factors that we have to consider
and the other part that is unique about
this
kind of perspective on infectious
diseases
is because the infection takes many
different forms
and so it's not a single disease it's
really a variety of conditions
that are defined by multiple molecular
factors
and systems in the body and so you have
to look
at the process of this infectious
disease developing
through the lens of systems biology how
does the whole system respond
to this pathogen infection so
before we start i want to give you a few
slides
that we typically go through in the
context of these omixlogic programs that
will help
shape your thoughts around how to choose
a topic
for your project and i'm assuming that
the majority of you here
are interested in joining one of the
programs where you will be able to get
guidance throughout the program
and then how to go from just selecting a
topic
to finding the right data set and then
guide you
to some resources where you can find
methods
to analyze and explore those data sets
so how do you choose
a topic for your project let's imagine
all of us are going today
to start thinking about addressing a
particular topic
so before i begin i want to ask you
a question how many of you have already
thought
or are already involved in a research
project where
omics data is either currently used
or you're planning to use it as a part
of your research
so if yes if you are
planning or you're already doing such
research
please put number one if you are
not sure but you are interested in that
put number two
right so just two categories okay
i'm assuming that there's nobody here
that doesn't have
any interest in using omix for their
research and so i'm just gonna leave it
at those two options so number one
you're already using or you have a very
specific plan
or number two you're just interested
you're just thinking about it
okay thank you very much and as we go
through
the next couple of slides we're going to
address
both of these topics so for those of you
that already have collected and are
using
the data and for those that are planning
to or thinking about it and beeps as we
go through please
count up the numbers so that we know how
many of each group we have here
so how would you choose a topic for your
project this is going to start with
those of you
that are just planning to right you are
just thinking about
developing a project idea and maybe
you're thinking
how do i do something like a publication
that i read
or maybe you're thinking how do i do
something in
an area where i'm naturally interested
in but i really don't have the data
to start doing that kind of an
experiment
so that's the first point that i think
we should start from
is the topic that you already know and
care about so if you're currently doing
your phd you've selected a topic you're
maybe
thinking of a particular experiment
and you want to understand how to make
it more
impactful how does omics data factor
into this
if you're already conducting experiments
and you've collected data
you might be thinking how do i find
additional data
that i don't have the capability to
generate myself
but i really want to use it to make my
project more
impactful or i want to develop a new
hypothesis
but i don't have the means to generate
the data
so that would be the first step is
really having
a topic that you know or you care about
and to ask yourself is that a topic that
i know and care about
is can you prepare a few slides to
explain
the topic background and can you see
yourself spending a few months
researching the topic so really
for those of you that are planning some
kind of bioinformatics analysis
even though it's just data analysis it
still takes time
so you have to be prepared to dedicate
at least several months
just to the analysis the second part
is what will be interesting to your
audience so i'm assuming that the
majority of you
here are already in some kind of
research
and so if you think about your audience
what is that audience that audience
could be your peers
your mentors other faculty they could be
the broader research community
and this is not a trivial question for
any of those audiences
within a niche there's already a niche
within
every domain there are specific topics
that are
more uh interesting they're more
on top of everybody's mind and so
that's the second component here the
third
component is that you have to have the
data
and you have to have um some kind of a
body of research that is available about
that topic right so if you are planning
to conduct this research
and there's no data you're back at the
same place right so it's got to be
something
that comes from availability of data
now in between at the intersection of
these three
is the project that you want to focus on
and i want to talk about this a little
bit more
in detail because that's where typically
most of the participants that we have in
our programs
fail they fail to quickly identify
a relevant topic that is interesting to
a broad community
and find data that can help them
make some kind of an interesting project
out of that question
so i think that defining that question
making it specific
and making it actually possible to
execute
is a big challenge that needs to be
overcome
now when people publish they typically
publish
from primary data that they have
collected
and that is the raw data the first
hand observation that they have
themselves collected
in many cases you are not going to be
the person that generates that primary
data because
so much data is already available but
that doesn't mean
that you cannot start your project from
there
and so what we will do in the context of
the first part of our program
is we're going to kind of explore all of
these
sources of data to generate a hypothesis
or develop a problem or a question
and then find the solution or the answer
and i think that that has to do
with an overview of literature but also
the available data sets
and it has to do with a good founding a
good
established understanding of methodology
how have
others extracted insights from data sets
that they described
and so the typical process that we
recommend
is to start from where you are and try
to
define what is the specific
data set what is the problem statement
that you have
and then trying to work through on how
to make that
into a much more specific question
because that really
can help you then narrow down the number
of options that you have to do
your analysis and it will
streamline or simplify the
interpretation at the end
and so the first part is to review
available sources
and to categorize them by
some kind of type for example you can
think of
different types of research articles
that present
the current topics or that focus on one
specific
thing you can focus on a number of
different categories but you have to
build out
that overview or that kind of a
landscape
of where you are compared to what's
already out there
and then it will be more clear where
are the specific gaps unanswered
questions
maybe controversy right so some people
don't agree with each other
and maybe a debate and those are
typically
the most interesting things to address
so that
gap those unanswered questions and those
debates around
different topics is the place to focus
to define your question or hypothesis so
here what we want to do is we want to
kind of review what's out there make it
more specific
where do we want to focus and that
typically
will be in the place of gaps and
unanswered questions
now a good place to start is from
existing projects right so a part of
review
and by the way this doesn't have to be
just in your domain
is to see how have other people
tried to answer questions with data
and so what we've done is over the past
several years we've gone through
publications
that focus on specific types of problems
and specific types of data
and have extracted insights from that
data by processing
exploring and analyzing those data sets
so we've collected
a number of projects that you can
start with as a springboard into the
process
because they clearly take out the
methods
break down those methods into tutorials
that you can follow
explain the data set and how the data
set was collected
and why that data set is an impactful
way to study that particular topic
and once you've gone through a few
examples it becomes
almost easy for you to start thinking
about the data
in terms of a hypothesis that could be
answered
with a given set of tools and so when it
comes to
your project you are really going to be
able to take those examples
and leverage the same types of methods
to apply to a data set of your own
so this is how the program that we
envision is going to work
we're going to first follow through and
learn about some of the basic data types
and how they are processed and analyzed
then we will introduce case studies and
those case studies will provide
you with a good overview of the topics
where the data came from how it was
analyzed
and what are the results at the end
you should develop a framework of how to
apply
such thinking to any new data set or a
problem that you identify and so then
we will go to focus on your independent
project
where you will frame the problem and
framing the problem means
writing out the specific question and
how you plan to address it
then we'll go through finding the data
sets and that data
will be of different types and different
formats that we will
review process the data for analysis
with the right tools and today i'll show
you a few examples
perform in-depth analysis trying to
develop a statistical model that can
either prove or disprove your hypothesis
and then we'll also work with you on
communicating the results of the
analysis which is a very fulfilling
process because
it helps you get feedback early on from
a community of like-minded people
that will point out all of the details
that you need to address
for your final project so let's take an
example
and think about how to frame the problem
what does that actually mean
so there are several types of problems
out there for example
you can take a clinical problem right so
we all live
in the era of personalized medicine
and we can think of clinical challenges
in the context of personalized medicine
for example
patient stratification how do different
patients
respond to different pathogens how do
different patients respond to different
treatments
are there specific groups of patients
that we should be aware of
disease classification and diagnostics
how can we differentiate one disease
from another
maybe one disease staged from another
disease stage
maybe it is the predictive component how
can we identify
potential responders to therapies that
will respond better
to a therapy based on our mixed data for
example
and also we can look at mechanism of
disease and disease progression
and that is more of a research question
and nevertheless
it plays a major role in how all of
these
other questions could be addressed
another
category of problems are related to
intervention
and so for the pharmaceutical and the
biotechnology companies what is
important for them
is to know biomarkers how can we
understand
specifically what is the molecular
process
that can help guide our decision making
that can help define
a diagnostic test we can think of
detection of toxicity right when there
are interventions
how do we know that those interventions
can have side effects and those side
effects could mean
toxicity at the maybe in vitro stage
as well as an analysis of molecular
mechanisms
of a drug action or target discovery
right so how can we use the information
that we have
about a particular interaction between
an intervention
and the host at the molecular level and
understand
what are the targets that we can focus
on and how to eliminate the targets that
are potentially
unreachable or unrealistic and also
a big domain in everywhere in
including infectious diseases and
non-infectious diseases
is drug repurposing and repositioning
right so how can we take existing
compounds
and apply them to a different type of a
challenge
or how can we take the same drug
and combine it with another one or maybe
modify its mode of use
so that it is positioned in a different
way
so after we framed the problem we need
to find
the data so let's take a look at a few
data sources where you can potentially
identify
a data set for your research okay
so i'm going to go here to ncbi
and please follow with me to ncbi
this is the link
and please let me know once you've
reached ncbi
by putting yes into the chat box
and as we're doing that i want to say
that
the majority of the people that have
answered the first question
said number one so they're already
working
on a data of their own they've collected
their data they're
doing some analysis themselves and nine
people
said two so nine people said that
they're still planning or thinking about
a project
okay so please let me know once you've
reached ncbi by putting
yes in the chat box thank you muhammad
encourage
all right thank you okay it looks like a
lot of you
have okay so
another question for those of you that
already reached ncbi
on a scale from one to five one being
no experience and five being expert
how many of you have experience or what
is your level of experience
working with ncbi so one to five
five you're an expert one
you don't really know this is new to you
all right so i see that hosea
wrote number five so i'm going to pass
on the microphone to jose he's going to
guide us
on a brief explanation of how to use
ncbi
and that that's a joke so for those of
you that are
very familiar with ncbi
that is a great thing what i think we
want to do today
is just look through some examples of
data sets that we can quickly find and
i'll show you
how you can use them even if they're
very large
even if they're something that you
probably don't want to download to your
computer and
load up your laptop with this data set
so
here we have a search box on top
that searches for all databases okay
so think of any concept that
you're interested in or any topic that
you're interested in
and let's just see what's out there so
i'm going to take the first five
examples that you post in the chat so
put down something
more or less specific okay so not just
the name of the organism
or a disease propose something a little
bit more detailed a little bit more
specific
so what type of a data set what type of
a problem statement what type of a
question do you have
that we can try to find data for
okay i'll take the first five
suggestions from the chat box
okay any suggestion does anyone have any
project
in mind that they don't mind sharing
with the rest of the group
okay so whole genome sequence again
whole genome sequence
is going to be a little bit difficult to
define because
that could mean anything right whole
genome sequence of what
what pathogen what okay great
so ahmad you can try again um
let's go to the next one gulshan
nyc tuberculosis
so i don't know if that's referring to
new york city or
did you want to say mycobacterium
tuberculosis but again that's broad
right that's very broad that's just
a pathogen okay let's go to the next one
or matayo
is saying drug target for parkinson's
disease okay
let's try that okay so drug target
parkinson disease that would be number
one
okay uh a bukhari is saying
microsatellite sequencing data
again something i think a little bit
broad let's be more specific apply to
what what kind of a disease
or or something like that okay
a beer is saying rna microarray data for
the
lnk gene okay so
i have a little bit of a problem with
that because if you're using
microarray you probably don't want to
just choose one gene
right instead choose a pathology or
choose
a specific situation where this type of
data will be interested let's go on
hosea is saying comparative genomics of
covet 19 strings okay
perfect so covet 19 strings we don't
even have to
search anywhere we can look over here
source code 2 data so we'll take a look
at that example and see what kind of
data is out there
human microbiome and soil transmitted
hellmann's okay joelna a quarry is
asking a very interesting question so
that's going to be number three
let's see what we can find for for that
and this is personally
i do not know anything about this topic
and that's what's
exciting about my job i get to learn
about all of these interesting things
uh from you okay uh james
so we have one two three four so this is
the fourth okay so we have here
alka tenuria disease
james i would recommend being also a
little bit more specific
just the disease itself is probably too
broad so think of a
more specific question let's go to the
next one mohamed sagir
saying single nucleotide polymorphisms
of ace ii
i think it's interesting so let's take a
look but
i would mention that it's probably also
very broad right so let me
first of all fix this h2
okay so the last one let's see who's
going to be the lucky person
plasmodium falciparum that data okay so
that's interesting but let's
again be more specific let's go to the
next one
mans mansonella species in africa okay
let's let's try
[Music]
okay so let's go to the first one
so the first project that you proposed
was
drug target in parkinson's disease
and so let's take a look briefly at what
types of data
are available and how much so there's a
lot of books
and publications and different kinds of
references
in literature which obviously we would
expect
but here we have some information about
genes now
who knows what does geo stand for
does anyone know what geo stands for
gene expression omnibus okay thank you
abeer
that's in fact correct so we have here a
number of
gene expression data so we don't have a
lot
but we have a few data sets now let's
think whether
gene expression is a good way to study
drug targets for parkinson's disease
i think it is a good uh data type
because
when we look at how a drug
affects a particular tissue or a cell
line or a whole
whole organism what we really want to
know is whether
there is a protein a receptor on the
surface cell
or some kind of a surface protein that
could be accessible for a drug
is playing a major role in this disease
and therefore if we interact with it we
can potentially make a difference we can
change something
so i think that's a perfect example so
let's take a look at what kind of data
do we have here
as a drug target for parkinson's disease
so here we have
gene expression of a53t and
corrected ipsc driven to d8
neurons and exposed to paraquat and
monet
okay so a lot of gibberish that i
personally don't understand so i would
love to learn more
and i can click here for more and read
about the organism experiment type
summary
the overall design and potentially even
a publication that i could read
but let's go and see what do we actually
have what type of data do we have here
so here
it says we have 12 samples and the
important part to think
right is how can this data inform me
about making a reasonable question that
i could be answering with such data
so what i see here is that we have four
different groups
in each group we'll have three
replicates and those replicates
are corresponding with some condition so
if i was to start looking through the
data sets
i would need to structure the data in
such a way that i can
ask questions by for example making a
contrast
between one group and another group
or maybe through classification where i
can identify
different features that are specific
that are unique
to a particular condition so it looks
like
if i'm interested in finding a data set
to start asking
questions about some particular drug
or a pathway for a new drug target
this would be a good data set to start
okay so
for the first one we found data in about
a couple of minutes
let's go to the second one so here
it's obvious that we're going to find a
lot of data every lab in the world that
was shut down for any other purpose
found a way to repurpose their research
to study source code 2 and so much data
has been generated
just in the context of this pandemic
that it surpassed
every other pandemic before this
including ebola virus cells 1
zika etc in fact we saw a four-fold
increase
in the number of genomes generated every
month
for sars cove two compared to all of the
other
types of uh previous outbreaks combined
so i think there's a huge number of data
sets you can see that there are over
185 000 sra runs
so who knows what sra stands for
i'm assuming some of you that put number
five for the previous question
are very familiar with these
abbreviations
so please let us know what does sra
stand for
[Music]
all right excellent thank you a beer
sequence read archive
exactly so here we will find compressed
fastq
files that contain sequencing read data
and from those sequencing reads we can
study
gene expression genome variation we can
identify
groups of different viruses inside
patients etc etc so over 185 000 of
these
53 000 nucleotide records so
genomes or genes or proteins clinical
trial data publications and references
so
really a whole collection that you can
scroll through so i'm not going to go in
detail
anything you want to ask about
coronavirus most likely somebody
generated some data that you can find
and study that let's take a look at this
one very specific
problem here human microbiome and soil
transmitted helmets so if we look here
we're struggling to find any raw data we
have some
publications we have some books but we
don't have any data sets so let's try
to find nevertheless what is going on
with these soil transmitted helmets so
the first thing that
i already know that there's a lot of
data on the human microbiome
so i can pause with that real quick and
look for soil transmitted helmets and
see if i can find anything for that
and it looks like i can now because
i'm interested in the microbiome i know
it's not going to be in the gene
expression omnibus data because that's
going to be gene expression
and i'm looking for microbiome a
different type of data so probably
i want to go into the bio project and
see
what can i find here and here
i do have one bioproject that deals with
the metagenome
okay so what do we have here the impact
of
enthalmentic treatment on human gut
microbiota in western kenya
cross-sectional and pre-post deworming
comparisons
i think this is exactly the type of data
that you're looking for
right i forgot who asked this question
but
do you think this is a data set that
could help you study this
uh topic okay
whoever okay great so there's your
project
so here you have 211 samples
already for you right you don't have to
generate a single sample
because first of all you probably want
to understand
whether this data set contains some
interesting insights
into what you are trying to identify so
there we go
a complicated challenging research
question and we found data for it in
just a few minutes
all right so another question was single
nucleotide polymorphisms of
ace ii so whoever asked that please add
a little bit more detail in the chat box
so we can kind of take this further
but it's an interesting question we all
have heard
that h2 is the primary target for the
coven 19 source code 2 virus
we know that h2 is expressed in the
lungs and other tissues
and maybe the question is whether there
is a genetic component
to people that have acute reaction to
source of 2 or a milder reaction to
source of two
maybe some other types of information
like ethnic background
or other important information could be
a factor here right
so obviously we're going to find a lot
of data here
but i think we need to structure the
question better to find
good responses so ace2
how do we find single nucleotide
polymorphisms
single nucleotide polymorphisms are
found in
genome sequencing data and so instead of
looking for
single nucleotide polymorphisms in h2
i would just probably want to find some
data set
that i could query or i could search
through to find
polymorphisms typically found in maybe a
healthy population
or maybe between different tissues or
potentially between different species
as i can see here right so if i
focus on the homo sapiens phase two
let's search for that
okay here i have
um again bioprojects
so let's take a look at bioproject
okay here we can clear all because we're
in the filter for metagenome
and because this is going to be genomic
data
unfortunately i don't see genomic data i
see epigenomics
other which i don't know what that would
be transcriptome
so it looks like maybe
we need to search through
um so so whoever proposed this do you
have
a more specific question here
okay i'll wait for you to come back
because i think that here
in the context of ace 2 it would be
interesting to
see what the specific question would be
that does it have polymorphisms probably
yes
do you want to just compare different
people or do you want to find a
particular
position or how do you want to use that
information right that's i think where
you need to think a little bit more and
propose
how to make it more specific okay so now
let's look
we have manzanella species in africa
so again unfortunately this is kind of
broad
right so i think if we just look for
manzanella
and then we see what kind of information
do we have about
manzanella it looks like we have some
geo data some gene expression data
some bio project so let's take a look if
any of these
are in africa
okay let's see where was this collected
if we can find
out
looks like a very recent uh data set
a genomics okay
do we know where it came from
let's see
[Music]
um
okay unfortunately it does not tell us
where was collected from and it's a very
recent sample
but i can imagine that you would be able
to find
data depending on what is your research
question what are you trying to find
right
so the point of this is that i think for
the majority of the projects that you
proposed so three out of five
we found data very quickly for the other
ones
it took us a little bit of time
primarily because
you need to be very specific when you're
asking the question just like those
three good ones asked right it's
the microbiome for this particular
pathogen
and we found that data right once you
can define your question
with the type of data the type of a
organism
the type of a specific question that you
have that helps you very quickly
answer the question about whether that
data exists
and remember let's go back really
quickly to that slide
when you choose your problem you need to
care about it right so some of you have
proposed
your questions presumably you care about
them
number two it has to be interesting to
your audience so that's up to you to
decide
but three that's an important component
you have to have
a data set to start working with to be
able to work on that project
so that's an important component here
that we always go through
so we've thought about how to frame the
problem again
several examples of how to frame the
problem
and how to explore whether that problem
could be answered with data
now let's talk about processing the data
so many of the data sets that we have
looked at
will require processing of raw data
for example when we looked at the
sequence read archive
those contain individual read reads
from sequencers those need to be
pre-processed
then they have to be mapped they
potentially if it's gene expression you
have to go to
quantification maybe differential gene
expression
or you're free to start asking the
question
what is the signal to noise ratio what
kind of signal am i looking for
that can help answer my question so in
the context of this program
we'll take a look at several types of
data sets
including viral sequencing or
metagenomic sequencing we'll take a look
at
genomic data how the whole genome
sequencing whole exome sequencing
or genomic genome assembly for pathogens
works
and we'll also look at transcriptomic
data so we'll learn how to process that
data
to go from individual reads to a table
of expression
a big step that many people overlook
is the exploratory data analysis step
so as we saw we found
a number of data sets and those data
sets
have been prepared by different labs
different
hands did the sequencing they did it in
different conditions
we need to know that the data is solid
that we can use it that it doesn't have
any artifacts that are going to lead us
astray
so let's see whether we can find some
data set
and quickly explore it okay
so here we have expression profiling by
array i'm just going to use this example
to show you
what kind of data exploration could be
meaningful
in this case here we have
six or sorry three replicates per
condition
so let's take a look how can we explore
this data
so here we have the table so let's
download this table really quickly
it's going to be a big table but we'll
take a look at what's inside
okay so i'm going to take this table and
let me
unzip it
okay i'm just going to open it up
in excel and let me read here a little
bit more
what does this data describe so
parkinson's disease pd is characterized
by extensive loss of
a9 dopam dopamine
dopaminergic da neurons
in the substantia [ __ ] pars compacta
snpc
okay okay
um a strong association has been
reported between pd
and exposure to mitochondrial toxins
such as the environmental pesticides
ferroquad miniv and retinol here using a
robust patient-derived stem cell model
of pd that allows comparison of cy
nuclei
mutant cells and isogenic mutation
corrective controls we identify
mitochondrial toxin-induced
perturbations
specific to a53t syn mutant
a9da neurons we report a novel molecular
pathway whereby
basal as well as toxin induced oxidative
and nitrosate of stress inhibits the
mef2cpgc1 transcription network in
a53t hns compared to corrective controls
contributing to mitochondrial
dysfunction
and apoptotic cell death our data
provide mechanistic insight
into gene environmental interactions in
the pathogenesis
of pde furthermore using small molecule
high throughput screening we identified
the mef2cpgc1 pathway
as a new drug target for therapeutic
benefit in pd
so here we know that this is a mutant
right this is a53t mutants so a53t
this is the mutant uh and
here's another a53t a53t right so what
is
pq and uh so i think that these were
um paraquat maybe
mb paraquat and moneb and rotnum so
maybe these are the pesticides
so maybe this is the mutant with
pesticides this is the control with
pesticides
this the mutant without pesticides this
is
the control without the pesticides so my
question would be
as i want to explore this data could i
use
would i be able to see clearly
differences between
the control group and the treated group
or between the mutant and the control
so let's try and figure that out
so here's my data i'm going to just
change this to id
and actually i'm going to use
uh i'm going to use this because right
now i'm not interested
in specific genes here
i have the names
of probes it looks like
so what i okay okay so this
is not useful okay unfortunately
with this data set it is designed around
probes and so i cannot just take
the data set as a table of expression
what i probably will be able to do is
get the raw data
and find that data inside okay but
theoretically
what i would want to do is i would want
to explore this data using something
like principal component analysis
to see whether the groups separate and
the important next step here
is to be able to structure this
analysis in depth right so here
we have an example of what i wanted to
show you unfortunately the data wasn't
ready for it which is actually
eighty percent of the case that's what
you're going to find but once i
structure the data and i find the right
table
i could perform something like principal
component analysis
that would help me design the specific
contrasts
that i could turn into biologically
interpretable analysis okay
so i'm going to pause here and ask you
if you have any questions about what we
did
and how you are thinking about
your own project so help does this
ability to find reference data sets on
ncbi
and public domain repositories does it
help
your project do you see yourself being
able to leverage these resources
to be able to ask such questions
okay so the other example that i briefly
wanted to show you
is this one okay so the second
problem that we will take a look at
today
is working with large numbers of data
sets so again
you can see here is there 211
samples okay so to process these samples
you actually don't have to download the
data to your computer so in the context
of our program we're going to provide
you with
access to our server platform
that is a big data platform so please go
with me to server dot
t bio dot info and we'll take a look at
the second
data set okay so here
what's important is to understand how
was this data prepared
okay deep so maybe you could share the
demo account details
okay so what's important here is to
understand how this data was
prepared and you can see here that this
is
amplicon data using aluminum my seek
and it is metagenomic it's pcr and it's
paired
and because it is metagenomic using my
seek
i probably think that this is going to
be amplicon data
so what it's going to simplify for us
is that it's only going to provide us
with sequencing of the 16s
ribosomal rna gene and that will allow
us to study
data about microbiome composition
and species richness so if i want to
analyze all of these datasets again one
of my options is to download all of them
to my computer and start running
a pipeline on my computer but i can see
how this can quickly get out of control
because there's just so many samples and
each one of them
is fairly large so instead of
doing that what i will do is i will
send the results to run selector or
over here go to file
and download the run info table
and what this will do
okay what this will do is it will create
a table
from which the server will itself pull
the data from
ncbi and i will be able to run
this analysis without requiring
any kind of computational power from my
own computer
so let me show you how to do that okay
here we have the runs 211 runs
and here there's a download link which
typically i could use
using sra tools to download to my
computer but i'm going to skip that
okay so here we also have
the description okay they were taken
from different
dates it looks like
and
all of them okay so this table
let's go to the server could be analyzed
with either the data 2 pipeline
right here or kind 2.
so let's use this amplicon 16s
example to see what we can learn
from this data set so here we have a
demo
of what this pipeline would look like
and so i'll just briefly explain
once the data is loaded you go through
the data to
workflow which clears up the sequencing
reads
and prepares a table of operational
taxonomic units
that is then cleaned up and
prepared for analysis using phyloseq
that will show us how the distribution
of species in different samples varies
based on in this case i think infection
so as a result you will get a number of
outputs that include visual outputs
and table outputs that could be further
used to study these
in detail how do we actually upload the
data
instead of the demo now with the
credentials that beeps have provided you
cannot do this but
once you join the program you'll get
your own personal account
here i have the ability to select silva
as my reference database
i will add the file that i just
downloaded
as an ncbi run table so i'll do add file
and here
i'll take this table that i uploaded
and here i actually don't have
a supplementary text file
but i'll just upload something else and
now i can
start this pipeline so without
downloading
any of the files just providing the
reference
links to ncbi and defining what groups
those samples would fall in
i can start this pipeline and create for
myself a full metagenomic analysis
understanding species composition and
richness between those different samples
in the microbiome
okay so briefly i think what we went
through today
is how to find data
which could include looking on ncbi like
we did today
it can include raw data on different
repositories like
sra bio projects and geo
and other dedicated databases
for example somebody mentioned
plasmodium falciparum
so there is a full database of data
specifically on plasmodium falciparum
plasmodb then
we talked about how to do exploratory
data analysis and that can include
running
something like principal component
analysis or looking at
summary statistics for my data
understanding whether
i can use that data and make reliable
inference from my analysis
then we talked about doing meaningful
analysis
translating my question into a model
into a test in a particular analysis
that i will want to run and finally
you will get to your result so
what is the result what should be
included
in the result of my analysis
so as we said in the beginning you start
with the project name
and selection of your topic you then
perform
specific tasks you downloaded the files
from somewhere and you analyze them in
some way
all of those steps need to be recorded
so what's going to be important in the
context of this three three-month
program
is the ability to keep a journal where
you record
all of this information that later on
will be included in your poster in your
report or in your publication
so there you will describe who generated
the data and how
what are the sample names and how do you
find those samples
if somebody else wants to reproduce your
analysis what are the specific
analyses that you've run how did you
transform the data or manipulate
it before you ran an analysis and so all
of those
tie in into your results and
discussion how does your result compare
to what other people did
especially if you took some other
people's data and
what does your analysis contribute
what new information does your analysis
contribute to what is already known
about this topic so this is just a brief
overview today
that we saw about starting your project
finding the data and planning your
analysis
i think that in the context of this
program we're going to expand much more
on how each one of these steps is done
and how your analysis could be
impactful and reproducible and so to
speak about how to register
for this program and start this journey
i want to pass it back to bipsa to talk
about registration
thank you so much elia
i would want to quickly uh share my
screen
and talk to you all about some resources
and the registration process so firstly
i want to divert everyone's attention
to this blog post where we have detailed
out
all the different uh
processes that we are going to go
through in this three-month program
so starting with why are we going to
study bioinformatics for infectious
disease research
to the training schedule now i want to
take your attention to the training
schedule first
so that we know that when we are
starting when the program
is going through the different stages so
in phase one of the program which we are
starting
this friday which is on january 29th
we have a hands-on workshop
uh where we will be discussing about the
bioinformatics analysis of public domain
data
so today we had an overview of this
topic
and on friday we are going to do an
in-depth
study of this as well as you are going
to be
participating in taking part in that
hands-on sessions together with the
mentors
and next we have our session on february
1st and as you can see
we go on till february 19th
so we have seven sessions in phase one
where we are learning from the mentors
discussing all of these important topics
like how to uh download the data like we
saw today from
ncbi as well as other public domain
repositories
how to use the different uh kinds
of analysis steps why they are useful as
well as going through different courses
which i will show you
in a very short while now moving on
in phase two what we are going to do
is have a research project so we will
have four sessions dedicated
and that will start from february 26th
where we start learning about how to do
the different kinds of literature review
we again went over this today and elia
gave
us a very short introduction to the
entire process but
when we are going over in the session
we'll do it an in-depth study will learn
from
different projects which are already
available on the platform
and try to come up with our own research
projects
and once the bioinformatics
for infectious disease program ends
what we will do is we will also have a
hands-on training program
on genomics and transcriptomics in phase
3
which i will be coming to later so how
do you register
for this program which starts
on january 29th and ends on march 8th
so this is the link i will also post the
link
right now in the chat box so that
you can see it
with me and explore the link together so
if you click on get started you will be
able to see the different pricing for
the program
and you can choose from the ones that
you are interested
in joining moving down you will be able
to see
all the different syllabus for this
program
and the different sessions that are
going to be there and there are more
information
testimonials as well as information
about the courses
the projects in this site
so this is the registration page if you
are joining the program please
complete your registration via this page
now once you are registered
you will have access to different
courses
which we will guide you in the different
sessions that we are going to be having
on how to get started with learning
and then applying the same logic so that
at the end we can have the projects
and this is the first platform which is
the edge ut bio info if you have not
already registered on the platform and
joining us
in this webinar for the first time
please
register yourself on hu.t hyphen
bio.info
i will also show you a few free
resources that we have
for all of our participants
and secondly the other platform that you
will have access to
is a coding platform so in this platform
you will be able to learn about
r and python as you go through the
courses
so this is all going to be available
as you become a member of the program
and of course
the platform that elia has just given us
a demo about is the server t by info
platform so these are the three
platforms that we will be
utilizing along with the other public
domain
platforms as well as tools that are
available
to understand infectious disease viral
data
and utilize it for our projects now let
us
take a look at some free resources that
we have
available for you on our website so the
first
free resource that we have available
is a resource on biology genomics
so this is a free resource that i
welcome every one of you
to take a look at uh you should be
logged in to access the blog
and you will be able to take a look at
the different resources
and the public uh domain data
repositories that we have stated here
including ncbi which we saw today as
well as
ncbi virus which is another great
repository
on finding data sets related to
viral diseases so you can go through
this
resource at your own time and if you're
already registered for this webinar you
will also receive
an email from our end from marketing at
pine dot bio
where we will be sharing these resources
with you
so the email id again to notice
marketing at pine.bio in case you have
not received something or you would want
to reach out to us
and once you have uh gone through this
resource
another resource that we had shared as
part of our previous workshop was
answering some questions that many of
our participants in the workshop
asked us so i hope that this is also
something that will be
helpful to a lot of you who are just
getting started
in learning about bioinformatics for
infectious disease research
as well as interested in working in
infectious disease
so with this i want to bring your
attention
to a few projects that our previous
participants
had completed as part of our program
so let me quickly go ahead and show you
some of these
projects so in our last
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program that we had last year
a lot of our participants submitted
their projects
here we have grace and priyanka they are
both from sri lanka
they did this project on human bronchial
organize as a pd
in vitro test model for sars cov2
and they also share their feedback about
the program that you can see here
and their experience and then
we had mikhail from atlas he works at
atlas
which is a company in the uk so he too
uh studied the structural predisposition
to acquire a poly basic cleavage site
for
influenza and all of these videos that
i'm going forward in this program are
available in our youtube channel which
i'm also going to be
showing you in a while and we also have
this project by
dr anita gansha and dr
emika and where they were looking at
the transcriptomic profiling of
sarskoftu infected cell
lines to understand the mechanism of
action and repurpose
drugs for covet 19 treatment this
project was recently
finished and dr gansha is going to also
lead this training
so this is how once you're going through
the training of this three month period
you are able to not only train yourself
but also come up with
projects of your own now let us go back
quickly to the web page and let me show
you
some other free resources and blogs that
you can take a look at
so as i was pointing out mikhail so
mikhail here
shared some things that he thinks all of
us
should take a look at on why he
recommends these omics logic programs
that
we run at pine biotech so you can take a
look at this blog
as well and going ahead
here is a link to our youtube channel
even the video of today's session
will be available in our youtube channel
so you can go ahead
under pine biotech or you can also
search us
in the search bar as fine biocheck and
you will be able to
come across a lot of these videos that
we have in our channel
you can also see we have a video here of
uh dr
anita when she was sharing about
her experience and her research in our
previous webinar
so we have free webinars like this all
the time
that you can take part in and also be
part of some of the programs here
and i hope that this is something that
you find very
informative and lastly before you go
i want to invite you to join our groups
in linkedin and facebook because this
will make you part of our growing
community
and i hope that you will be able to
contribute
and also we will be able to help you
work on your own projects as well as
help you with your progress and now i
want to open the session for
any questions that you may have
so we are now open for questions uh
please
ask your questions you can unmute and
ask your questions
or if you have any other questions you
can put them in the chat box
so thank you so much for attending
today's session